on peut pas demander au peuple français
comme dans plusieurs villes à travers le
pays
où la non augmentation des salaires par
rapport au coût de la vie
[Musique]
les professionnels de l'éducation mais
aussi de la santé et des employés du
port
la manifestation longe la gare
étrangement calme les cheminots font
aussi grève en région seul un train sur
deux circule
[Applaudissements]
dans les rues des appels ado meilleur
salaire pour affronter l'inflation mais
aussi des critiques des réformes comme
la retraite à 65 ans défendue par le
président et son gouvernement que tous
nos présidents nous parlent qu'il faut
ces relations qu'il faut faire des
efforts que c'est fini l'abondance
l'abondance c'est pas pour nous c'est
pour les riches nous notre abondance
c'est simplement de regarder dans le
frigo si on peut finir la fin de mois
parmi les manifestants les travailleurs
du secteur pétrolier sont bien en vus se
sont en quelque sorte eux qui sont à
l'origine de ce mouvement de
contestation les employés étaient
raffineries et des dépôts de carburant
du groupe Total énergie font grève
depuis plusieurs semaines maintenant
pour exiger des augmentations de salaire
ce matin un coup d'éclat des syndiqués
ont bloqué certains accès à cette
raffinerie la plus importante du pays si
d'autres syndicats se sont entendus avec
leur employeur ces travailleurs de Total
énergie réclament toujours une
augmentation salariale de 10%. une
manière de palier la hausse du coût de
la vie mais aussi de toucher une part
des immenses profits engrangées par le
géant pétrolier cette année on a
peut-être un impact qui est plus visible
que les autres plus fort que les autres
on va pas en rougir c'est voilà la
population doit comprendre qu'on donne
le la maintenant il faut qu'ils suivent
n'empêche certains commencent à perdre
patience
qu'il y a partout donc ça a commencé à
énerver les gens je pense à la pompe la
situation c'est légèrement améliorée
mais les pénuries perdues environ le
quart des stations services françaises
sont toujours touchées pour pouvoir
aller au travail conduire les enfants à
l'école tout ça c'est ça va devenir
nécessaire cet autre automobiliste voit
aussi son quotidien perturbé c'est vrai
que c'est pour les automobilistes c'est
ennuyeux mais je soutiens totalement les
grévistes quand on voit le les comment
les coups ont augmenté
lui-même fonctionnaire il a justement
pris part à la mobilisation dans sa
région dans la foule comme au sein du
gouvernement une question la crise des
carburants a-t-elle déclenchée un
mouvement soutenu de contestation il
sera fait Bouvier au clair Radio-Canada
Wavre
[Musique]